[Music]
foreign
I feel like I slept on a pile of bricks
oh well I slept like a baby knowing that
all our cash is safe and sound right in
our mattress no wonder my back hurts
why'd you do that well with all these
Banks closing I just figured it was the
safest place to put our money right now
you know the banks are insured right oh
yeah but what if the insurance companies
go under too I think that's a lot less
likely than someone coming into our
house and stealing it how
how we keep
them maybe I'll put it back in the bank
[Music]
most people know that the image of all
your hard-earned paper dollars sitting
in some dusty Vault isn't actually how
it works though the first Banks were
likely ancient temples that guarded
wealthy people's currency the
Renaissance brought a major Financial
Innovation called fractional Reserve
banking which allowed Banks to lend out
the majority of their deposits at
interest of course and only keep a
fraction of them on hand see this is
exactly why I'm so freaked out what
happens if everyone wants to withdraw
their money at once Allah Mary Poppins
we'd be out in the cold I want my
tuppence with me thank you very much
well it's true Bank runs and failures
were a common consequence of fractional
Reserve banking in the past in the
mid-1800s rampant railroad speculation
led to Big losses for banks and hundreds
failed in an awful domino effect after
the Great Depression of 1929 FDR stepped
in to stabilize things with the Banking
Act of 1933 which created the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation the DIC is
a government corporation that provides
insurance for depositors if a banking
institution covered by the FDIC fails
account owners are made whole up to 250
thousand dollars now this insurance is
something you'll never have to pay for
at least not directly the FDIC is not
publicly funded they get their money by
charging the banks for their membership
based on the bank's level of risk this
ranges from well capitalized which means
a 10 or higher reserves to debt ratio
all the way to less than two percent
known as critically under capitalized
the lower the reserves the higher the
banks Do's the FDIC also plays an
oversight role when an insured Bank
drops to around the six percent reserves
mark it can force the bank to take
corrective action like change management
or sell-off assets it can also take over
failed Banks and manage the sale of
remaining assets and debts like it did
for Silicon Valley Bank in March of
2023. in that particular case since so
many of the depositors had more than 250
thousand dollars the government made an
exception and reimbursed everyone in
order to shore up confidence in the
system and prevent a contagion of
collapse so it sounds like I can take a
breath death it also makes me feel
better knowing that since 1933 not a
single depositor has lost a penny of an
FDIC insured deposit and the government
seems more committed than ever in making
sure the banking system is stable so I
think our checking in savings accounts
are as safe as I could hope for but what
about our retirement funds our
investments and how think about it we're
not even at a bank we're with a credit
union don't worry honey Penny there's
another acronym that's got us covered
the ncu Sif is basically the same thing
but for credit unions and as for our
IRAs and investment accounts well that's
where the Securities investor Protection
Corporation comes in the sipc is
actually a non-profit governmental
organization that ensures the investment
Accounts at member institutions again up
to 250 000 per member but keep in mind
these forms of insurance only apply if
the institution goes under it doesn't
mean we're protected against our
investments losing value Commodities
fixed annuities hedge funds crypto money
you park in these kinds of financial
instruments is uninsured that's a big
reason why the crypto crash was so hard
on people overall the government and
financial institutions have done a lot
of work making the banking system pretty
safe for your average person which means
the 48 of Americans who report feeling
moderately to too very concerned about
the safety of their money can relax a
bit even though time seem especially
turbulent post coven but in reality
there's no such thing as a perfect store
of value whether it's stuffed in a
savings account or a mattress cash is
always susceptible to inflation
certificates of deposit and treasury
bills might have really long and steady
track records but they're not going to
return enough to help you retire on time
and as we've talked about in other
episodes stocks mutual funds and even
real estate naturally gain and lose
value in Cycles over time there's
nothing out there that's perfectly
impervious to loss but when you find
yourself getting especially nervous try
asking yourself the question what are
you wanting to keep your money safe from
if you're nervous about inflation eating
away the purchasing power of the cash
you have then you could move some into
an investment if it's about your
company's stocks losing value you might
want to mitigate that by moving it into
a broadly invested mutual fund but if
you're worried that you might wake up
and see the name of your bank on the
news making sure your accounts are with
insured institutions and under 250 000
per Bank should do the trick and that's
our two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
if you still think there's a way to
perfectly protect your cash from loss
you might want to check out our episode
should I invest in gold
[Music]